i'm a huge fan of your work and i really
want to thank you for giving me your
time today
thank you stephen um i'm going to ask
you the most important question of this
interview right up front
um have you been vaccinated yet that is
an important question and the answer is
yes my doctor called he had 10
he he needed i think to get the
vaccine you have to doctor's office they
have to inoculate
10 people so he called 10 people
come to his office he had the the the
stuff
so i was very lucky yeah i've been uh
vaccinated both both shots one of the
things that i'm
really amazed about um like the last 10
years
uh is that you do more every year
than people a third of your age it's
it's really impressive what you've been
able to accomplish
and i'm just curious a third of 50 is
what
exactly right but i am curious what has
the last year been like for you
because you're so prolific you know the
last year you've been sort of i'm sure
trapped at home like all of us using
the proscribed uh
instructions from i believe it's sag
screen actors guild
i have filmed uh several
uh hours of
the unexplained this is a a show i have
on the history channel at nine o'clock
on
fridays i have at home
been hard at work with a friend of mine
who's a poet
and another friend who's a musician
and myself we're making a really unusual
and i think at this point a great album
musical album and i'm recording into
a iphone with a mechanism
and i just recently re-recorded some of
it
at a studio i'm planning
to be to uh interview
three authors of books that i have read
that will be the theme will be the
how how how the world how nature is
unified
i'm going to do a podcast
i am uh
i'm promoting this film uh and
i've got three or four businesses that
are futuristic
i'm doing that uh businesses that i've
been at
i was talking recently about uh story
file
which is 3d uh image
maybe 50 60 cameras around you
and then trained uh questioners
you answer the question you shoot in 3d
and it's fed to an artificial
intelligence
and eventually in my case five days
the the material that you
put into the ai will be
serviced and you supplied with
the ability to press a button and ask me
a question
and the ai will answer so it's permanent
it's there for the end of time
that's incredible it's incredible man
so you could do five days like i did you
could do one day their uniqueness is
they can process
this thing so you could somebody could
ask a question and yeah
the ai will find the answer you can do
your will
on this thing can i so is this out in
the public right now where people are
about to i just finished my five days
i was focused on
getting those five days there's there
wasn't a question they couldn't ask me
and there wasn't an answer i wasn't
prepared to give
because i wanted to fill it out because
in my mind i'm hearing my kids
and my grandchildren my great-grandkids
and beyond that
press the button grandpa what did you
think of
and i answer like it's
mind-blowing it's incredible i i have so
many other questions on that but i'm
gonna
move on because uh because i so much to
ask you but
um i but you mentioned you're working on
another album
i'm a big fan of what you did with ben
foles
yeah i i'm a big fan of it and i'm
curious um
uh there's a song on the album called it
hasn't happened yet
and i'm just and i have to ask you um
has it happened
the whole idea behind the song was it
hasn't happened yet
is it if you if it's ha if you think
it's happened it hasn't happened
think of that dilemma there's a line um
in
in the song uh at my age i need serenity
i need peace
um have you gotten it a form of it
it comes and goes serenity and peace is
ephemeral
and you've got to pursue it you've got
to breathe it
uh serenity and peace is not
really i wouldn't characterize my life
as
serene and peaceful well i think i think
for people that are watching this
interview
that have not listened to your ben album
with ben folds uh
they should it's quite good there's
gonna be people
who have never seen your work younger
fans and i'm curious and you have a
a very a long career
what is the first thing or first few
things
you would like a younger fan to start
watching that you've been in
well there was a priceline commercial
out there
uh i don't know because i've had the
experience
the the the audience i have attracted
is like it's not singular it's
a six-year-old kid and a 60 year old
grandmother
so i've had the occasion with the
grandmother saying come here
uh johnny uh meet captain kirk and the
kids
looking around for captain kirk it's
over here kid this is captain kirk over
here
uh this is unrecognizable from
when i was 20. so
do i say uh young man
watch uh this uh thing that i did when i
was 20
or would i rather than watch senior
moment
and say this is a good thing for you to
watch if you want to recognize
me see this and see what age does
for you to you as you work your way back
maybe that's the way to go so because if
they looked at the 20 year old they
wouldn't recognize me
i'm talking to you and i'm thinking
i this movie's got to be a success that
uh
i if there's anything i can do to help
make it this because that
i gotta talk to steve so he realizes
that
this is a fun movie senior moment is
like
great fun and lots of laughs and and
promise that the future can be good and
you don't have to
[Music]
be desiccated to in old age you can be
full of life and love
i'm involved in so many things and
including
doing uh as much promotion as i can
for this wonderful movie so that's part
of what i'm doing
and part of you know i do a project and
part of what i do with the project
is bring it to the attention of an
audience listen i've interviewed a lot
of people over my 15 years
uh running collider and there are very
few people i've spoken to
that have had more impact on this planet
than i would say you
uh you've influenced hundreds of
millions of people other than an
asteroid you mean
exactly but i'm being very sincere when
i say you
you've influenced hundreds of millions
of people on this planet
maybe even over a billion in terms of
what you've done
with star trek and i'm just curious
what does that mean to you with you
saying that
i'm looking around for the person you're
talking to for as far as i'm concerned
i'm uh you know i've got this lovely
movie
and and i want to publicize it and i
hope people come and see it
and i hope you'll like it when you say
it's good i get a bit of a glow because
it's great and uh and then
maybe tomorrow uh i'll have time to go
get on a horse and
and you know i mean i'm in this
little life that i'm doing everything i
can to seek what sounds like the
the audio to seek new things i'm i'm
trying to
discover things for myself that i and i
love the information i go
wow i just read
about a spinach leaf stripped
of all everything but it's ma
but it's a structure and they're putting
blood
in there and it helps it doesn't quite
perform as a heart
but it helps a heart a spinach leaf
yes what does that like
blow you away of all the things we don't
know
we suddenly find a spinach leaf helping
mankind
that means a spinach leaf is is not
dissimilar to us
it's going to function in our bodies
it's that's yeah i i haven't heard that
it's crazy
i would say it was in the news i glow
in finding things out wow i said i
didn't
know that it's a like finding a nugget
well let me jump backwards actually i
i'm always curious how people discovered
what they wanted to do and how did you
realize or when did you realize at a
young age that you wanted to act
i was uh at a
camp a summer camp for two weeks that
summer camp people go to
well i went to a summer camp in the
wilds of
the laurentian mountains north of
montreal
and at the camp you swim you them and
they put on a little play
so they put on a little play and i was
six years old
and i was part of the play and what i
did
at that point was make uh a speech
about the nazis it was during the second
world war
and the curtain went up and i did the
thing i did the speech and
and then as it was the end of the act as
the curtain was coming down i saw people
crying
weeping the curtain went up and they
applauded
my god i made people cry and got
applause
and later my father picked out my boy
bill
i never did anything else i've never
done anything else
i've never gotten a check for
unemployment i never got
all i've ever done my whole life is
entertaining
what did your parents say to you when
you decided
don't go you're not allowed
did they really say that oh my father
was irate
you got a college education and you're
going to go what you're going to you'll
be a hanger on
you know you build you can't do that so
when you ended up on broadway in the 50s
montreal is very close to broadway did
your family come down to see you and did
you sort of say
um yeah no broadway you're on via
we had a 12-week limited run of uh uh of
something by
uh uh by uh marlowe
a classical play on broadway so we did
our 12 weeks we
got a good audience and it closed now
what do you do
bill come to montreal
i get i get it so they still at that
point they were still like come home
my father died i i uh my
i loved my father uh admired respected
he died when star trek was just
just on the air he died in 1968 so
that's one year into star trek and it
wasn't very popular
i think he died thinking i wonder if
bill's going to be
a hangar on he died of a stroke so he
was alive
for a while before the stroke got him
when my mother was there and i i
in my imagination he's thinking of a son
i wanted to give pause because that was
a very very serious
dramatic pause but it went on too long
right exactly
something that people don't realize is
that you were
christopher plummer's understudy um
uh well before you worked with him on
star trek and i'm just curious
how many nights were you sitting there
watching him work thinking
you know wouldn't be the most terrible
thing if he lost his voice tonight
so this great director uh
comes over we're all sitting on the
stage shatner
you're going to understudy christopher
plummer great henry v
so we're in the first of rehearsals
so during that rehearsal period it was
about
three or four weeks i was playing
uh henry v's brother
which is a small role and he just stands
on stage for a while
it doesn't say too much
something the universe was taking care
of me
something told me to
learn the words
and i'm in a
a closet of a room uh
that they had rented for me or i had
rented that
so i spend
because we were working we were
rehearsing another play during the day
this is at uh stratford festival
rarest to play during the day play at
night so my the time i had was limited
and that in that limited time in those
three or four weeks
i learned the words i drilled i drilled
i said once more into the breach dear
friends what's more another one
once more into the
play opens and the next day we start
another play rehearse another play
play opens chris is fantastic chris
plummer is fantastic
we start rehearsing another place six
days later somebody taps me on the
shoulder
and says you got to go on tonight.
what do you mean i don't even know the
names of the other actors
i've never said the words out loud you
can you go on and i say
yes
a play i've never rehearsed i don't know
the choreography
some of the actors that didn't know
their names i'm performing the longest
arguably the longest running uh speaking
part in the english language and i get
through it
i heard you were very good that night i
was very good
how could be very good imagine what i
could have done
if i had four weeks rehearsal sure being
able to say you were very good that
night when you stepped in in the
situation
that you were dealt is still a major
accomplishment
just getting through the play yeah
imagine
imagine if i had stumbled or i'd why
wouldn't i have forgotten a word
because if because you know
you're working on several levels as a
stage actor
you're dimly ten percent we're aware of
the audience what's
what's happening out there you're dimly
aware of
uh what's going on stage is something
wrong here on stage
and but mostly you're focused on the
words
on the acting of it the performance of
it
and especially in a classical play when
there are things like opera
where you have to be larger than life
you're you're there
you're getting you're there's a lot of
stuff going on something goes wrong
you know somebody said coughs what
as simple as that your mind goes out to
there you've lost the lines
you worked on a lot of um guest roles in
television
in the 50s and 60s i'm just curious what
was it like back then
trying to book a role was it similar to
the way it is now where you do a lot of
auditioning
was it could you sort of talk about what
it was like back then
so i did this play uh by marlow
it's on the tip of my mind um
and as a result uh agents and people saw
me
and i got a lot of attention uh so i
got an agent i didn't have to worry
about that uh
people saw me i went on to the edinboro
festival came back to new york
and that's when people asked me to be
in their whatever it was in their
television show
in their movies when they flew me to
hollywood in their plays in
on broadway it was as a result
of having said yes to go to this
this uh small which became an enormous
uh classical company uh in stratford
ontario
um so i didn't have to audition
the way you you hear and go back and go
back people ask me to be in their plays
i don't remember auditioning for
anything uh very lucky
you if i'm not mistaken you did an
episode
of uh ed sullivan in 1958.
i could be wrong but i think i think
you're right we did a segment of the
play
exactly so i'm just i'm just curious for
people that don't realize younger people
ed sullivan at the time there was
nothing bigger and sullivan was
it was the show sunday sunday night show
exactly so i'm just curious what was it
like for you
going out on ed sullivan at the time and
were you nervous because
that was a really big deal well i was
we did a segment of the play that i had
rehearsed i i knew the words the reason
the reason uh mostly the reason actors
get
nervous is they're not quite sure what
what to do
or their words or their movement or
anything
that that that to me is what
makes actors nervous i'm sure there's
other other reasons
but here i was i rehearsed the play and
i'd been playing it on broadway
and uh and and they asked us to do a
segment of the play
on that show so i wasn't nervous
uh and doing doing a live television
show
which i did a lot of in those years was
very much like doing a play
you had hit marks you had to do that you
got to say the words you got to you know
move
off to another set it was very much like
doing a play
rapidly uh
so although nervousness was always a
factor
in one way or another it was
it after about four or five
times of doing the play in front of an
audience
and you got to know where the laughs
were whether
you would be pretty secure in what the
rhythm of the play is
and therefore your nervousness would uh
would disappear
i did a one-man show on broadway i
toured
with a version of it in australia and
canada
but i rewrote it rewrote the whole thing
and the director
of the original play hadn't really
directed it
and i had written it i sort of directed
myself so i was
responsible for everything that evening
the day before i ate something that
didn't agree with me
and that day of the opening on broadway
i was sick
and i had to go to the theater and i was
coming out of every orifice including my
ears
and i had to stop the play in the middle
of a broadway opening and say ladies and
gentlemen there's been a
there's been a a a a technical
problem i'll be right back i went
upstairs and i changed my underwear
opening night on broadway in a play that
i don't think
i rehearsed it at all it was opening
night in a new play
was i nervous now i knew the material
thing
making them laugh is that it was i was
on high and ended on a high
and it ran it ran and we got great
notices
i want to go backwards though um did
your dad watch you on ed sullivan
and after that performance was he like
maybe he can make it
i don't remember him saying anything
like that
maybe quietly he might have thought hmm
but he never said anything
i don't remember him saying anything i
think he was so
upset with me being in this
milieu that he
i don't think he ever forgave me or
or liked it or whatever uh jumping into
why i actually get to talk to you with
senior moment
i eventually i was gonna get there what
was it about this script and project
that said
i i have to do this well somebody comes
to me and says we got this script here's
read the script we want you to
there's not there too much money in the
thing
but but everything so i read the i read
the script
i've done that on several occasions go
wow
i gotta do this wow i gotta do this so
i jump into it and and because
it's a wonderful piece of material
because
this the lead is a guy a
race car driver now older doesn't drive
races anymore
but races around palm springs with his
beloved porsche has an accident
and the government uh the the city takes
his license
to drive away they've taken his ability
uh uh he's taken his youth away they've
taken his joy away
and what is he going to do what is he
going to do now
and then stumbling around trying to find
some meaning to his life
he finds love he finds a life and it's a
great you know happy ending it's very
funny
it's very uh there's a meaning there
there's a heart
it's a wonderful feel good uh come out
of the theater
smiling and and having felt good and if
there you
want to find a message it's life goes on
don't worry uh you'll be you'll be all
right life
does go on uh true or false you actually
did this movie because they told you
they'd give you the porsche
i would have people do films for
different reasons
and by the way if you said porsche you'd
be uh
kicked out of the out of the green room
it's porsche my bed i don't i don't have
a porsche
so i don't actually know the the proper
you know now you know
yeah i won't mess up again no
uh you get there's some really fun
scenes with you and christopher lloyd
i'm a huge fan of christopher lloyd as
well can you sort of share what it was
like working with him
he's a funny guy first of all he's
he's worked on he's
evolved a very funny character i mean he
is
nah and he's kind of like half mad
with the hair and the thing he's that's
not him he's very educated
very well-spoken guy uh he's just
he's got he's got himself a character
and he's plays that character uh
often so it comes as a shock
for him to say something meaningful and
intelligent
and we would have talks about everything
and we were in this car for long
periods of time so we're in each other's
uh
uh life quite a bit
so we talked uh and he's this wonderful
character
he's a he's a terrific guy really liked
him
and he's this wonderful actor very funny
guy
there's a scene in the movie where you
have to represent yourself
um in a courtroom uh actually with
christopher lloyd
um did you have flashbacks to being uh
denny crane again
uh probably probably
uh you know everything is different and
you're trying to make a difference so
yeah there probably was a flashback to
this wild character
i you mentioned earlier and i know about
you that you like to
improvise and sort of tweak dialogue and
make it your own
um how was it on this film did you know
did you interject
like how basically uh how did you work
on the script if
at all i would do it the way the author
wrote it
and then asked to see if i could do it a
little bit differently and
i would try various things and sometimes
it worked and sometimes it didn't work
but
always true to the to the uh
condition of the script and the and the
author i would
may get i would get it so it was
good for the director and then asked
if there was time could they do it for
me and
fairly frequently bad time with props
and costumes
through your career have you like
borrowed a lot from
sets do you care about that kind of
stuff or
is it had i known that these
things these props were worth a lot
i mean thousands and thousands of
dollars even a
costume so uh
i never got i never did anything i never
got anything
but people walked off with enormous
amounts of wardrobe because they were
always making new wardrobe
the wardrobe would get too dirty would
wear out
because they always thought the show
isn't going to last
sure but i actually also don't even just
mean star trek i mean
denny crane i mean i bought some danny
crane suits
uh they were lovely suits from one of
the more elegant uh
uh men's shop here some actors are like
you know i i don't i don't want any of
it and others are like i i steal
everything
uh i don't i don't steal i'd say i'd
like to have this
sure yeah and they say no and i go oh
[ __ ] when you think back
on uh tj hooker that was where you
actually began directing
um what was it like actually trying to
helm episodes back then while you're
also the star
well you're certainly working on at
least two levels
uh how did i do in that take what's
so-and-so doing
and and staying within the confines of
what you were saying
so it's difficult but i i think you
evolve
a technique and of course there's always
the playback
i wouldn't recommend it but if but since
i loved
directing so much i love the idea of
conceptualizing
the frame and the actors in it and the
and the fluidity of the camera
uh i i love doing that uh there were
times
more than once when a director fell out
and they said
can you direct this and i would
that day see the set and
uh set up a choreography that worked for
the camera
and it worked well it worked well for me
one of the things about episodic
television like that is that
it can sometimes be hard for the
director almost has to
maintain the style of the episode and
what's come before
and it's very difficult sometimes to
throw in like a cool camera angle
or you know also because you know how
many pages you have to shoot each day
was that something that you were
cognizant of at the time
very much so you know usually it was a
10 page count
as the show got less and less popular it
was in its fifth season
and they were thinking of the cancelling
there was less money spent on the budget
so there would be less and less
people in the shot if you had a group
shot you know sometimes 10 or 12 people
i remember the producers saying well why
didn't you have more people in the first
i said i had 10 people
to shoot a crowd scene you know so i
tried to place a piece in there and i
gave by again move the camera
because he didn't know that they were
cutting down on the budget
as as the show got uh poorer and poorer
but uh as for the style
i i thought uh
that i was setting up a style anyway i
loved the the the movement of camera
and tried to make the the shots the way
the way the shots were used to be
in live television there was always that
beautiful
uh choreography which at times works
and then cut in between so that you can
get that shot
i once did a shot took me i've forgotten
how long to set up a shot but had in it
a beginning a middle and an end i didn't
need to cut
i had the shot i had the close-ups and
come back in and when
on the wide shot it ended and then the
producer came down on such
as bill you got the coverage and i said
there's no coverage
no coverage and it was all there it was
it was a winner
it was one yeah uh i be
i i listen obviously i love star trek
like everybody else
but i have to say that i absolutely
loved galaxy quest
and i'm just i mean loved and i'm and
i've always imagined
what would that movie be if you guys
had actually made the movie the original
star trek
cast uh have you ever thought about that
because
it arguably could be if that had
happened
maybe one of the best star trek movies
ever
this is the way i look at it maybe i'm
completely wrong
so i have to ask you about it
i never saw the movie you never saw
galaxy quest
never saw a galaxy really
no do you know what it is it's a
spoof right well it's it's actually it's
it's it's with a lot of love actually
it's very sincere with the love of
of of star trek and with fan fandom
it's it's actually not spoofing it as
much as having like a sincere love
letter
oh that's wonderful to hear i i i
i need a psychiatrist to explain to me
why i haven't seen
any of the of the uh star treks even the
movies
um and i don't i really can't give you a
sincere answer
i can say you know i don't like to look
at myself which is true
but the movies i'm not in uh the
the iterations that i i'm not in i don't
know why
i i it's it's it's like uh i'll flip
through
um television uh
and see star trek and i'm not in that
star trek and wonder
why don't i watch the next generation
why don't i watch
these guys are friends of mine
i've spoken to a number of actors who
for example game of thrones
after they were killed off on game of
thrones they never watched again
they just they were done they've been
there they've done that
maybe maybe but still you know people
loved all those uh
i mean even now the the star treks that
are on are very popular
why don't i watch i had a terrible
experience
some piano praise for star trek they
invited me
and there was this young lady and i'm
telling she's in the next
or she's in the i think it made the
might have been the next because i think
it was a year ago
uh and you come out and you say so i'm
so glad to be here
in the room beside the stage they have
the teleprompter and say alright here's
what you say
and the guy on the teleprompter is
saying all right here so i'm reading
i'm so glad to be here tonight and i i'd
like to introduce and i'm gonna and i'd
like to
thank you very much and good night uh
could you make the font little
uh bigger please for me
okay done
as i'm getting on stage the young lady
is here and i'm here
and the stage manager says all right
bill you go around there uh
a young lady you go you go that way you
meet down stage
that's marked we didn't have any
rehearsal
you're on walk around get down hit the
marks in the mark
and i'm looking for the teleprompter
teleprompter is not on
jesus the teletubbies holy oh my god
you want to stand there the the
nightmares the teleprompter goes out
because you don't know what to say so
you're waiting there and there's
applause and people
and i'm looking at the lady and look at
the teleprompter goes off and i start to
read
okay and another thing is that and i'm
reading words
that i hadn't rehearsed but i thought
they've rewritten it
everything has been so spontaneous so i
read all there's
oh there's what i say and i say that
thank you to good night
we go off our way and somebody
says are you aware that you read what
the young lady was going to say
i said no they didn't tell me she was
going to say something
yes and her agent somebody was there
looking at me with angry eyes
[Laughter]
i'm so appalled at what i did
i can hardly breathe it you imagine it
was their
moment to be introduced to the american
public before the show went on or as the
show went on
and i stole her moment inadvertently you
know sort of like the oscars when they
announced
uh la la land winning instead of
moonlight
right exactly you know what
consternation
but nobody knew except her and her agent
and
probably they're still talking about how
awful i am that i
stole her moment but but it was you know
nobody told me and there's no rehearsal
and
and on came the teleprompter by
interviewer in the future i will
uh pass on a sincere please do my
sincere apologies
i i tried to make backstage but i don't
think it
registered now i wanted to ask you uh is
it true that david e kelly cast you
uh as denny crane based on seeing you in
the priceline commercials
i believe that's true uh he was looking
for
somebody who who was similar to that
character
and i i i remember vividly going to
breakfast
with him in westwood and uh
him saying things like uh you know this
character is a
a little senile and my saying i can play
that
you know and uh that kind of thing
uh yeah yeah uh
i i believe that what you've just said
is true
uh you won an emmy for your portrayal
uh of denny oh two i'm sorry two i'm ver
i'm
very sorry this is my totally my my
fault what did it mean to you looking
back
now um what does it mean to have won
those two emmys
and did you even did you think at the
time that you had a chance of winning
no i was of course there at a table with
everybody
and i felt myself i've forgotten who
announced it
it was an actor and i and i remember
i i rest in you know what iris is you
focus in on one small spot
my eyes focused in on the lips
because if i saw what all i was looking
for was
what is he going to go
and he goes and i was already cheering
or or not pretending not to um
yeah i was uh that was a lovely moment
uh my last thing for you uh i you
i'm a big fan of animals i i really love
supporting animals and i know you
love horses um and i'm all at all
animals
i support many charities dealing with
animals
yeah i read something very interesting
and cool which is that you
did a star trek cruise but would only do
it if they
did not have the interactions with the
dolphins
because um you did not support the you
know that kind of
stuff i do not support that but i don't
remember
if they said that that's lovely because
we now know with all the studying going
on
that those uh animals that are kept in
those
uh water cages are being driven insane
by the lack of space and no matter how
big they would make that
that cage uh it's still a cage and the
orcas
some of them are pelagic thousand miles
out there
and some just swim around an island and
eat
salmon but all of them are in movement
all the time
and interacting with the family the
family
is the important unit that's how they
interact with each other and we now know
that it's cruel there is an argument to
be made
for zoos and and the animals that are at
zoos
it's a tough question whether to have an
animal in a zoo
[Music]
you people can go see the lions and the
tigers and say we got to save them
and we don't save them but at least
they have a familiarity with the animal
but uh and i could argue either way
i don't know what what the answer is
about zoos but certainly the the uh
orcas and the dolphins who are highly
intelligent
we don't know the limits of of their
intelligence we don't know
whether they say you know uh there are
these
things that we look up there and we see
these upright people they don't seem to
like to get wet
you know i can't believe they don't like
water my god
yeah or my god yeah the god i mean we
don't know
what they're saying and doing we don't
know they've got bigger brains than we
have
what are they doing listen i got to tell
you when i was younger
i saw this movie uh i think it was
called star trek
and dealt with whales and it had a real
impact
on me and the way i looked at the world
absolutely
you know um but i wanted to ask you
specifically what is it
because obviously you ride horses and
you've
really championed horses when did you
sort of fall in love with horses
and could you sort of talk about your
relationship with them as soon as i
got married and had some place of my own
i i got a dog my parents wouldn't let me
have dogs
because it uh if i remember correctly i
dirtied
the house and my mother was against so i
got a dog right away and i got a
doberman
and i've had nothing no other kind of
dog than a doberman
for all these years we my wife and i
elizabeth and i talk to the dogs
like they're people and they
they're three years old now and so in
the last year or so
they've begun to understand that what
we're saying
carries import they start to learn
that the sound of your words is
meaningful
and after a while you're talking to them
and they're talking back
in dog language which is mostly to do
with eyes and attitude and all that kind
of thing
both dogs
are talking to us anyway
so for me the dogs are my friends and
although
i i will tell them what they have to do
at times
there we talk to them horses
are less visually uh attentive
but they are attentive and after a while
when you're on a horse's back and i mean
after a while after you've ridden
and you've gotten rid of the nerves of
the horse
of being on a horse and you will
yourself to be
part of the horse eventually soon or
later
the horse and you move is one at your
best
in competition you are part of that
horse
i've had dreams of running with the hor
of uh being on the horse's back running
effortlessly in the
in the pasture i've had occasions uh
being on the horse where the horse takes
off in a pasture
running running with me the
motion the emotion and the beauty of the
horse
is what is so attractive on that note i
really want to say a sincere thank you
for giving me your time
and i'm pretty confident your dad has
enjoyed your career even if he is
not right here thank you pleasure
health and happiness thank you same to
you of course